la dernière étape du grand prix des
savanes a été fidèle à ce que l'on
attend d'un peloton en fin d'épreuve au
départ de sinnamary 72 des 77 rescapés
du peloton ne comptait que deux minutes
de retard sur la tunique jaune un
maillot endossé dès le prologue vendredi
par le martiniquais yanis 6 2 10 dès les
premiers hectomètres le plan de course
est clair il faut tenter de décrocher
six deux autos mito à iracoubo
jean-michel club de le cg edf et gdf
compte 29 secondes d'avancé sur le
peloton
quelques minutes plus tard il est
rejoint par loïc john le cg n'offre à
yann et patrice d'anaïs condos du cds m
un groupe qui ne pourra pas faire
fructifier son avance puisque le peloton
sous l'impulsion du madinina bikers et
du vcs est revenu à hauteur des fuyards
c'est en place depuis d'encours ou que
les attaques ont fusé de partout et là
en grand leader
rien n'est si d'audi a non seulement
résisté aux attaques mais il a surtout
mis lé bon braquet pour protéger son
avance de quatre secondes au général
maillot jaune assuré le sociétaire du
madinina bikers à accompagner le groupe
jusqu'à la ligne
la victoire d'étape se joue elle revient
donc à james granville du vcg qui
devance kravis olivès du vcs troisième
place ou miro stanis de le cg la course
est partie très vite la martinique
agirait ben non on avait pour consigne
de glisser chose qui était très dur très
dur parce que pour mes coéquipiers
bougez pas trop à la fin je sens sur
l'art avec la rage
on s'était fait piéger je rate et
fallait concrétiser chez ce type au
général final c'est donc il ya ici de
l'idu madinina bikers qui remporte cette
deuxième édition du grand prix des
saveurs de toi je vous ai été assez
positif de la seule couleur magna baker
avec le prologue j'ai senti que j'avais
un peu la pression sur la qos
donc ça c'est maurice est pas une vue
dans le prologue
après s'il suffisait juste de jouer avec
l'équipe se qualifie pas très bien fait
et la dernière étape val a fini en
beauté
c'est ce qu'on a fait on affine embouti
le podium du général est complété par
gravir nivesse du vcs et creuser diassé
spidia de l'ajc 231 de la martinique